you
[Music]
[Music]
are you not entertained welcome to the
Halloween edition of the VR betting show
presented by the Caesars Palace sports
book
this is Kelly Cleopatra Stewart and I'm
the show Centurion cabby Xerxes Richards
Cleopatra's been stacking bags of gold
recently tell them where you're actually
Oh sir cease we went at perfect six and
Oh last week with our picks on the show
including 200 augs that one out right I
love weeks like last week or week 7 bets
covered by a nearly average of 12 points
per game
can I keep it up guess you guys have to
stick around to find out I've got my
weekend picks starting right now
[Music]
let's kick things off with the marquee
matchups of the week we got the Cardinal
plus 12 at the Saints total 49 call me
crazy I know I'm not Sean Payton but how
do you sit the hot hand that is Teddy
Bridgewater he's now 28 and seven
against the spread and his career as a
starter this is just too many points to
lay with an injured Drew Brees
wants to have a bye I like the Cardinals
here I'm not gonna bet them it is mylène
for this game
Panthers plus four and a half at the
49ers total 40 and a half
yes Carolina is the most popular
underdog of the week and that terrifies
me I wanted to make this my best bet so
bad love betting against these fruitful
teams like the 49ers but Carolina's 17
in four games to spread all time versus
the Niners Plus have covered in nine
other last ten in San Francisco 20 plus
mile an hour winds run that ball
Christian McCaffrey I like the Panthers
plus four and a half packers minus five
and a half at the Chiefs total forty
seven and a half Sunday Night Football I
know this one's come up a lot and of
course Matt Moore starting under center
as opposed to Patrick mahomes but I am
NOT ready to lay points with Aaron
Rodgers in Green Bay in that hostile
Arrowhead environment Andy Reed 91
straight up seven and three against the
spread in his career versus the NFC
North when coming off a win of 10 points
or more
let's push all that aside because it
doesn't matter we're gonna cash a ticket
yet again with another prime-time under
18 and 5 on the season we're going under
47 and a half points let's recap the
marquee matchups of the week remember a
lien is not a game that I'm personally
betting but if you insist on having
action that's the direction I'm leaning
towards got a lien on the Cardinals but
I'm betting the Panthers and Packers and
chiefs under
March and the smile of Bill Belichick
look I've never faced the Bill Belichick
defense before but I know how Sam Darla
felt on that Monday night with the
people's parlay at Owen seven I to the
scene goes to conquer the fear of losing
another week I find the emperor Chad
Julius Caesar Johnson and his new game
this is pick or treat since this is a
Halloween episode we're using a
different way to pick winners the
mystery box your weekly winners are in
there in order to pick the winners
whichever helmet you pick is the team
I'm gonna bet on for those three team
parlay all right yeah three matchup to
get through dolphin Steelers
we have a very sweet smelling Pittsburgh
Steelers hope it's the Dolphins I'm
going with Coral Gables come on bear
come on Dartmouth you've had some kind
of clairvoyance it is the Miami Dolphins
find that helmet come on find the best
team in the league I feel it best team
in the league got Steelers okay second
match of Browns Patriots find that
helmet there we go going with the
Patriots
but guys you in
oh we've got the Cleveland Browns baby
oh well yeah how does that feel
there's got to be time to subscribe your
tongue breaking every time Fred please
it must be David Copperfield this is Tom
Brady you are correct
our final matchup is two Broncos and
Colts oh oh we've got the Colts ladies
and gentlemen
we're going Broncos we're holding Denver
Broncos it's okay it's okay thank you
Mike you're welcome Indianapolis Colts I
appreciate the gesture but only my woman
can feed me grapes and I'm gonna dye it
anyway well you might be on a diet but
I'm hungry for some wins in this
Halloween edition of the people's parlor
picker treat Chad will my nightmare
season ends if we leave it in your hands
to make the pigs in whenever you thank
you definitely the scariest most
unpredictable way to get football picks
the people have chosen the Steelers -
thirteen and a half the Colts - five and
a half and the Patriots about a ten and
a half I have a feeling how you're gonna
react to this Kelly but what do you
think
yeah cabbie it looks like another woman
- weak again for the people's barley
that is a lot of chalk - and that clears
me on the Halloween edition of the show
I see people picked the Broncos Colts
nacho and that's actually a game I'm
playing as well let's take a look here
my card for week 8 the theme of this
week's show is NFL Road Dawgs right they
have been cashing in an unreal clip 44
24 and one against the spread this
season plus 18 4 & 1 when facing
opponents coming off a loss the Broncos
plus 5 and a half at the Colts total 42
now I know a lot of sharp guys played
the Broncos today I am NOT one of them
Emanuel Sanders was traded away to the
Niners Joe Flacco is terrible against
the Colts but you know it's not terrible
this total now I know what's come down
but Denver has been cashing those under
tickets for almost the past two seasons
14 and 2 towards the under I like the
under 42 Chargers plus three and a half
at the Bears total 41 I'm just going to
put this out there I've been fading the
Bears all season and we're just gonna
keep rocking with mr. Biscay fading mr.
Biscay I like the Chargers 12 for and
one against the spread their last 17
regular season row games they got robbed
last week versus the Titans they don't
get robbed this week they win at Soldier
Field next up we got the Bucs puts two
and a half of the Titans total 45 and a
half I don't know what's scarier
Tabby's peoples parlay or betting on
Jameis Winston Jameis is terrifying the
guy throws five touchdown passes or five
interceptions
this week we're banking on touchdown
passes plus Bruce Arians 6 in 1 straight
up and against the spread in his NFL
career after back-to-back losses on
fading Mike's rival who's 4 and 9
against the spread dating back to
season we're rocking with the Bucks plus
two and a half and last but not least we
got the Raiders at the Texans I really
wanted to make this my best bet but the
producers wouldn't let me change it
during the middle of the show at the
Texans
total 52 six of the last seven games in
Houston have been cited by seven points
are fewer this Texans defense gave up
321 passing yards and four touchdown
passes to Jacoby presets give me a break
I like their car and the Raiders were
fading Houston at in our G Stadium just
five and nine versus the spread in the
last 14 games that is my card for week 8
cabby and hopefully we'll see a repeat
of last week when you went six and on
your NFL bets congratulations now if you
guys have ever wondered how pros like
Kelly can consistently beat the
oddsmakers we've got you covered in this
edition of export analysis through a
handicap wound martin shares the biggest
factors that he considers before picking
a bet what's up guys my name is drew
Martin sports bettor here in Las Vegas
Nevada talking about ways I've had
success and what I try to use the most
of it's finding change cuz when you find
that change it's from that point forward
the oddsmakers have less stats going
forward on what the outcome of the game
is going to be so whether that change be
at the head coach coordinator position
coach quarterback injuries across the
field I try to find those and use that
in my handicapping some stats I'd like
to throw out there that I use havoc rate
which is tackles for loss passes
defended and forced fumbles mainly
because teams that turn the ball over in
my opinion are more likely to turn the
ball over in the future so using that
plus you know the quarterbacks
efficiency throwing the ball down the
field is a huge data use as well so
using all of that together try to find
more winners than losers it's the name
of the game guys so if you have any more
questions feel free to reach out at drew
Martin bets on Twitter how the great
sounds like a stat made up
Halloween you can follow to run social
as he mentioned at Jewel Arden bets like
yeah that's his process what's your
process
yeah cabbie drew makes some great points
but remember every handicappers
different they're gonna weigh their
options drew is a great analytical
numbers based guy I'm more of a
situational better let's use the Cowboys
for example last Sunday night I knew
they would step up big against those NFC
East opponents like they always do plus
their stock was so low after that John
Jets loss I had no option but to buy the
most interesting pros in the ancient
world was written on Scrolls so let's
read from the minds of the public water
Evan asks Kelly what what's the best
advice you can give to a young amateur
sports bettor who has huge aspirations
on becoming a professional and making a
living at the sports bar yeah Evan it's
easy all you have to do is pick winners
all jokes aside picking winners is the
hardest part showing great discipline
managing your bankroll remember control
your emotions guys it's very important
say you go in five and you're mourning
that's the last thing you want to do is
step back up to that counter and get the
sports with more of your money and last
but not least always shop for the best
number does hedging depend on the
potential return on investment or are
there other unwritten rules to follow
when a hedge opportunity arises yeah I
think you have to take each individual
situation and analyze it from there but
I always recommend hedging whenever
significant stakes are involved I
usually don't have significant stakes
for a hedge so I don't hedge but what I
do like to do is middle that is when you
can win both sides let's use an example
let's say you're taking are you laying
six on one side and now you can take
seven and a half you can actually win
both bets at the gain wins seven and
always hedge anytime that you're
overexposed on a bet the date 78 wants
to know our 3t nine-point teasers better
than two point six point two minutes
yeah listen just don't bet anything but
to team six point Caesars minus 120 now
guys remember a teaser is a multi leg
bet that allows you to manipulate the
spread of each game again six point two
team teasers minus 120 here at Caesar's
Palace if you're not laying six
Blayne 120 don't make the bet actually
have a nice teaser for you guys this
week
Texans down to a pick'em Jaguars -1 this
is that's how I feel when Kelly
continues to press it each week with her
best bets keep stacking those stacks
Cleopatra Kelly what is your best bet
this week my best vet cashed again last
week with the Ravens Plus 3 I love when
those underdogs went out right we've now
hit five straight best bets I'm looking
to make it six in a row this week with
the Giants plus six and a half this
whole sports because people lined up
around the bar wanting to lay a
touchdown here with the Lions I don't
get it detroit largest margin of victory
this year was a field goal fine the
Giants just lost at home to the cards
shirt
Detroit's covered four of their last
five but I'm telling you the Giants keep
it close we're gonna see a lot of steak
wall and Berkeley today Giants plus
six-and-a-half don't forget to sprinkle
a little bit on that money line all
right cabbie time to recap my picks for
week eight these are listed in order of
confidence on how many units I'd
recommend you buy them each I've got a
four unit plan the Giants three units on
the Panthers chargers Raiders and the
Packers Chiefs under now remember a unit
of the standard bet amount should be 1%
of your bankroll I've also got chumina
plays on the Bucks Broncos and Colts
under and on my Texas jagwire teaser
French Roman
countrymen lend me your ears thank you
for joining us on the BR bedding so
presented by the Caesars Palace
yo Chad you killed it but what are those
thank you guys thank you these are
wonderful costumes making your bets
earn you the crown this weekend follow
us on our football journey at VR
underscore betting good luck to you guys
and here's still profitable Sunday
Halloween
[Music]